by 2018 70 percent of content
consumption will happen through
connected devices
every ad released to be first released
online and then on traditional media
the internet advertising industry will
generate over 300 billion dollars in
revenue
and benefit 1.2 billion people
an average person will watch over 60
hours of ad content every month
amounting to 30 days of ads in a year
excited to start a career in online
marketing
enroll in our suite of online marketing
courses
whether you are a fresh graduate or
entrepreneur our courses will help you
gain understanding of search engine
optimization content marketing social
media marketing pay-per-click
advertising mobile marketing web
analytics and much more
taught by bestseller authors like
avinash kaushik well-known google
evangelist our courses are also
accredited by omcp.org and aligned to
their certifications along with being
updated per the dynamic online
environment
with content built on a proprietary
global learning framework hands-on
exercises and backed by a 24 7 support
team you will definitely be successful
not happy with what you're learning our
industry first cash back guarantee
ensures 100 satisfaction or your money
back
so what are you waiting for
join simply learn and be part of one of
the most happening careers in the world
online marketing
you